going to be over shortly but we've got
irina crush who was in a must-win
situation irina you would have to agree
given how the especially after carissa
won her game you had to win and you
managed to defeat one of your main
rivals katarina nemtsov who had lost in
the tournament at all were you surprised
when she played this dutch against you
yes of course i was surprised by the
move f5 i mean that's the intention
right i mean it would be hard not to be
surprised by a move that your opponent
has never played before um so i think uh
she um did manage to surprise me there
and how did you right the ship at that
moment what were you thinking like whoa
what is this
yeah no i wasn't that concerned and
honestly i don't think it worked out
that well i mean to go i mean the dutch
is a very kind of specific opening and i
think it takes a lot of experience to
play it and so kind of going for a
position that you're not
you don't have a lot of familiarity with
of course i'm not going to play into the
systems that i've played before so i'm
just going to go and choose something
else that looks normal and i did think a
lot actually i had a long think after
the move f5 and move one just to like um
and i decided to play without the knight
on c3 uh which which worked out well
because i had um i always felt very
comfortable in this game she seemed to
be in terrific time pressure as a matter
of fact very early on based on the way
you played uh and then she played this
move c5 and took on d4 and it just
seemed to be giving you all you could
have dreamt for
yeah it was comfortable you know the
move f5 is very committal you know once
you have that you're always going to
have some kind of weaknesses in your
position and so white i mean it was hard
for her to find targets i thought she
kind of got well something like a
playable position but it was still um it
was still uh always like it felt like
quite nice for white um and i'm and i
mean these moments were kind of critical
and i had a lot of choices about how to
play but i think even with what i did
kind of very simple
um centralization
strategy it was always feeling nice for
white um you know i had the queen side
majority the strong knight on d5
um
and
i felt like you know then i improved my
bishop as well from g2
um
to e2
and
yeah i mean i don't know there was never
a point in the game where i felt uh like
i would not want to be white
right and
so
quick question for you arena write it
right at this exact exact moment did it
flash in your mind to potentially tr uh
sacrifice your queen
did you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah of course i mean i looked at that
queen sack a number of times i don't
know it didn't feel like like it didn't
feel necessary to do this here to begin
with it wasn't necessary but yeah those
ideas were definitely on my mind okay
yeah essentially you got the runaway a
pawn going down the board like you said
it was very difficult for her to manage
everything that was coming at her and
eventually you were able to win a piece
with this nice move rook a6 must have
given you a good feeling yeah like
around you know when i was calculating
before playing i guess uh the what did i
play played a6 or no i played queen c5
and then before i made the queen trade
right here like i calculated this line
um
with with a6 and then i saw that i was
going to be able to have that pin and of
course i really liked this idea because
it's not every day you get this
dominating uh kind of pin in a simple
position and
um yeah and i knew this position was
winning it's in fact it's even more more
easily winning than i thought because i
even have the strong bishop c4 bishop a2
idea and black is just like in total
zigzwang and i just wait until she moves
away from f7 and i can even go for that
right total crush and we've seen a crush
there end in
a victory for jeffrey beautiful sequence
by jeffrey attacking
the white king you are now a point out
of first destiny is not in your hands if
carissa does what she's capable of you
won't be able to catch her but you still
got to play the games yeah you know all
i can do is play my tournament i mean i
feel good when i play good games you
know um but it's true you know since i
cannot play carissa myself you know
things are out of my hands so i'm just
gonna try to
do my best in the next two games and
we'll see if i get any chances all right
well good luck for the rest of the way
thank you maurice
congratulations serena good luck and
your remaining
two games of these championship rounds
it's a very